Hello,
we are back live.
Hi.
I am late today once again
with a good reason for the most part.
I actually got up pretty early this
morning.
I started working on a new article for
you all.
I think it's one that people will really
like, but it's going to take quite a bit
more work.
I literally just wrote the intro
sections today.
Hopefully that'll be out within the next
couple of weeks. See?
So, what are we going to do today?
First of all, we have this nice sweep
result where we've solved 2048 pretty
well, apparently.
But what we're going to do today is
we're going to work on the drone sim for
a bit.
That's like the main plan.
I think we're just going to formulate
the uh the drone
objective as go to point and don't
collide
and like most things will be some
combination of go to point and don't
collide for this them specifically
Got to mess with these reward functions.
So,
most of these are not that bad.
I think the only thing that really needs
to change is
What's the easiest way to do this? So I
want to generate points
on a sphere.
This is going to be some obnoxious
function actually, isn't it?
This is the type of thing though that's
done very quickly in a shader.
Okay. So you get the cartisian
coordinates
from the conversion to spherical. I
don't know why you do it angular, but
sure.
Should be able to do it
as a pure function of time.
Oh yeah, I also I forgot that I posted
uh the trailer to YouTube
Why is it CCD?
Welcome to the boot. Oh, that's close
captions.
Okay. So, they both have I don't know
some small number of views.
Well, the guys I'm on these posted um I
forget what 12. Okay. 13 hours ago.
Cool. Trailers are up.
Yeah, I think regardless of how I do
this, it's going to be annoying,
but we'll just start on
I really don't like this type of Well,
to be fair, if I as long as I get it, I
can verify that this is correct
separately, I guess, and then I can do
the RL. So, normally I'm very adverse to
doing anything remotely janky because
then RL makes it way worse.
Thanks for sending over some drone kit.
Of course, Ben, have you gotten any more
of it?
They should all be there somewhat soon.
Heck yeah, man.
I'm still working on the drone stuff. I
realized that we can do a lot of demos
just as a function of like go to
position but with just like different
versions of that basically. So, I'm
working on that right
Well,
let's just say for now
going to do
Arrow and Omega
Radius.
Fine.
Guess that's spiral to cartisian.
Maybe something like this is not
terrible.
All we have to do is set a uh a per
drone target, right?
You know, this is actually not going to
be bad.
I could use a little bit of just chill
work like this for a bit.
The only mildly annoying thing is the um
the sphere math.
I think if we're clever here, I can
probably uh come up with a whole bunch
of
cool demos just based on this one simple
thing.
this needs to move
up to here.
Now all the agents have different
targets.
Now, this is actually going to be the
same exact thing as before, just way
easier,
right?
What are you using that auto complete.
Is this just now
can probably do like um
where's the sphere velocity thing?
think how we're going to synchronize
this for
Do we do it based on the initial?
Hope it doesn't diverge.
bit. So yeah, this works.
This here works.
And what else did we have? We had
follow.
This was the one that I didn't know how
to do cleanly.
This is technically like a move target I
guess,
right?
This can be move target
This is going to collapse them all to
one target for now.
Okay.
Uh yeah, not this at all though. I wish
I could disable multi-line.
And then what was the reward I came up
with? Yeah, negative.
So we just do reward plus
float
negative distance over max distance.
So
your distance reward
times density.
Okay, cool. So, compute reward.
Now, all this needs doesn't need decks
anymore. So, that's cool.
Hey, Major.
Daily grind continues as per usual.
Speaking of which, we have the daily
grind of fly killing because I had some
maintenance work and I see three flies
that I may as well just kill now while
that's easy to do. So,
I actually have thought about doing an
RL trained laser turret in moments of
frustration.
Seems like a lot of work and I don't
think I'd be able to actually sell them
for any reasonable amount of money.
You'd probably just get sued for
blinding people with them.
That's my guess.
I would very much like to just back the
damn things though.
Yeah, I've been working on uh one of the
things I've been working on here is
trying to figure out how we can just
reduce the number of stuff that gets in.
It is a farm and lots of just bugs and
things get in. And man, it's like you
think, oh yeah, it's no big deal. You
deal with a bug once in a while. But the
thing is, when you have stuff that like
lands on you once in a while, right, and
you look and oh shoot, it's a bug, like
every single time something slightly
itches,
you will think, "Oh, it's a bug." And it
will drive you insane.
Incredibly annoying. Yeah.
And actually, it's so buggy outside. I
stopped running outside. Well, first of
all, it's stupid hot here and I'm going
to be in California in a few weeks. I'll
be able to run there anyways. But other
than that, like literally I went for a
run for I think an hour and five minutes
and I had like four or five golf balls
sized welts on my back by the end of it
from just like big horse flies just
taking chunks out of me. You literally
like rip like a horsefly off of you.
this mid run. It's horrible.
So, I've been Can you even see that
here? Yeah, you can probably see in the
background. I got the bike and I've got
the URG.
I think you should make some from
scratch tutorial videos for some DMs,
integrating them, designing reward
terminal conditions, adjusting
parameters, bugs, and sweeping
hyperparams because the articles are
cool, but videos are always better and
more appreciated. I'm actually going to
take that quote. I'm going to put it
into the article that I'm working on
at the bottom right here. So, I remember
this. So, here's the issue with the
videos, right? Making good video
tutorials
takes an utterly stupid amount of time.
Like, a truly ludicrous amount of time.
Like the iceberg video that I published.
But I would want to publish something at
least if I'm going to release videos,
right? I'd want to release something
that's as high quality as my iceberg
video.
This was like this took me two weeks of
work. Language. This is like the highest
quality thing I could put out. All
right. I put the tux on. I did all this
editing. I probably could have made the
editing better if I just hired an editor
instead of doing it myself. We'll do
that in the future. But, you know, I
could have spent it would probably cost
me, you know, a few thousand dollars at
least to get a competent editor for
something this length.
Uh, and this thing got over the last
several months 3,500 views.
That's like simply not worth it.
The articles on the other hand
occasionally they take a lot less time
first of all and they occasionally do
quite well. So this one that I wrote
here, right, this has gotten 100k views.
This is actually like this is a
worthwhile investment of of my time to
do stuff like this.
I am actually working on a much more in
detailed article though. Much more in
detailed article.
You'll get this in maybe a few weeks.
That one will take quite a bit longer to
write, but nowhere near as long it was
it would take to make a video.
doing for gamedev but you know
a lot of yeah it's just like
if I were getting if people were
actually like go like using them I would
do it. Um, but I can't like justify
taking two weeks
to make like a tutorial of that form for
people to not watch it when I also have
a business to build.
And like I'm doing this double time
basically as is. Not always double time,
not consistent, but very often working
double time.
I pretty much work double time until my
I burn myself out and then I work normal
hours for a week or two and then I do it
again.
See the thing is like I literally did
stuff like that before as well. The
thing like when puffer when I did like
puffer 10
if you will check on the YouTube
This is like a full walkthrough of the
library. Didn't like nobody saw this.
I' like I tried a few different
experiments and it just didn't catch on
at all.
Really, the thing that has been best on
YouTube has just been the consistent
like people getting involved from the
live streams.
And this was on a channel that's already
had, you know, a couple thousand
subscribers on it as well because my uh
my thesis defense video did very very
well.
But the uh the YouTube algorithm is
super super fiddly and it's just like so
uncertain if like technical content like
this actually gets seen.
It was pretty rough. It's pretty rough
overall.
I also and I also don't enjoy it at all.
Like I like producing videos is like
horrendously mind-numbing
like time consuming boring work as well.
So, I basically have to torture myself
for like a few weeks to make a video,
like a a long form video like
I know how we can do this.
We can do it.
How about running streams and clipping
them and p pushing them
always general purpose and mostly mixed
recreational programming way.
You do realize like for that type of
content, it's not as easy as like I just
turn the stream on and like do a thing
for 30 minutes and then clip. Like
the quality of that is going to be like
way way way lower versus something
prepared.
There will be some more educational
content though. There will be
I have to figure out how to space it out
and like where to allocate the effort
because you know my main thing is not
educational content. It's kind of just
been like a recent thing that um Tuffer
has become so like relatively so much
easier to use than everything else in RL
that we're getting like lots of new
people which is awesome and many of them
have actually gone on to be productive
contributors to the research. uh it does
require me to rethink a few things as to
how they're framed because like when I
started Puffer Lib the initial audience
was RLP PhD and then it went down to
like you know ML PhD
right and then it went down to like AI
engineers and now we're at the point
where we have literally brand new
programmers doing this stuff it's like
ah crap okay I didn't position this for
any of I didn't position this for that
at all I have to figure out How to do
that?
Implementation of N forX
improving rewards network design
parts.
So like I can do that, right? But here's
the thing. Here's the thing that's just
jank about that, right? If I did that as
a prepared video,
I could do that entire thing in like a
one hour lecture
and like live with all the demos. I
could do that whole thing in like a
really good one hour lecture.
It would take me like
probably close to a month to make that
video.
If I do it as a series of live streams,
it's going to be like
It's not going to give you thorough
coverage because like you're not going
to see all those different things in the
context of several different examples
and it's going to be like you know many
hours
and people don't watch many hour videos.
Turns out
I have been trying to clip some of the
educational like tips and things um and
start uploading like short little clips.
It's a little tricky to do, but I've
been trying to figure that out, how to
do it more efficiently.
Like really, the main jam around here
is improving the research. I have to
figure out how to still make that the
focus, right?
This is a good algorithm.
How the heck does this work?
Some sort of like serious
Fibonacci number. That's weird.
Cool.
Some people watch actually watch them. I
do.
I watch long form stuff too. Very few
I I interned in uh in Fe's lab I think
in like 2014 or something when he was
still a student there.
Yeah. Honestly, the probably the best
way to motivate me to uh make tutorials
is to make bad tutorials.
So, we'll see how that goes. Um,
let's see how this article that I'm
working on goes first because like this
should be a pretty good comprehensive
article.
Actually, grab
this stuff. Well,
as references for like the type of stuff
that people are interested in.
This
obviously that's not going in the
article. I'll use that to write stuff
based on it.
Also, everybody wants more content.
Nobody wants to feed the puffer a star.
Go star the repo. It's literally free.
Takes 5 seconds. Did the puffer a star?
He's hungry.
I opened a PR for the drone and
simple
realistic motor. Okay, I will have to
look at that in more detail. Major, let
me I want to finish this thing right now
while I still like before I run out of
steam. I've already done a bunch of
stuff this morning. Um, I want to have
this environment done today so we have
like a standalone second drone
environment.
And then we're going to probably figure
out a way to like pull out the drone so
that the drone can just be the
standalone thing and we can like do all
the physics tests including motor lag.
I will definitely incorporate that
though if that is a a reasonable thing
to model it.
Man,
I will say I'm very happy about the uh
the reason that I started writing this
article in the first place is that the
last one did very well. So, if you want
me to write more articles or you want me
to do more of a thing, you know, go post
and support the current thing because
that all helps.
The article,
this one,
the new article is literally just an
introduction section. It doesn't have
any content in it yet.
I might like I might write on it on
stream uh either tomorrow or over the
next bit of the week. We'll see.
when I'm like sick of coding stuff, I'll
write on things.
We'll share code walk through.
Uh it's more of a how to learn RL thing
in general. So, it's going to point you
to a lot of other resources.
The code that seems like stuff that's
like more for the docs.
Like it looks like you want like an
expanded upon version of
of like this tutorial or whatever.
I probably should add like a sweeps
thing to this. I could do that.
adding sweeps,
improving rewards.
Improving rewards I will talk about in
the article. Network design I can
probably talk about in the article.
Talk about sweeps in general for sure
and like common bugs.
The article will direct you on how to
like implement things and it will have
you build things but it's not going to
directly be like this piece of code read
now this piece of code read this etc
etc.
All right, let me code my sphere. I got
to code my sphere.
Otherwise, we won't have drone things
Done.
You're also more than free to ask
questions here, Shadow, while um I'm
working on stuff. That's kind of the
point of the stream.
I'm Red Zep. Okay. You cannot people
cannot possibly expect me to remember
when they have different usernames. So,
if I get confused, just remind me.
I have like a bunch of people on here
and then some people have like three or
four different usernames on all the
platforms.
What are you trying to do? You trying to
confuse me?
The curriculum learning goal at the
moment,
it's to grow the puffer business so I
can get back to doing real research.
far beyond many frameworks beat with the
simplicity. I mean, that's the goal.
It's simpler.
It's simpler than everything, but Clean
RL, Clean RL is still kind of the best
for that. Um, but it is like a thousand
times faster.
It's not It's not that much more than
Clean RL either. Especially some of the
recent Clean RL stuff where they like
import and use. Like some of the newer
Clean RL stuff actually imports garbage
from SP3.
Like the original Clean RL stuff that
Costa built is the best.
Uh and like all the like the newer
stuff, it's just nah. Nobody nobody does
anything like reasonably. It's such a
pain.
Have you read the uh the quick the quick
start guide though? Shadow or Reds?
The quick start guide has a lot of good
stuff in it.
The article I'm working on is going to
basically be a very updated version of
that. Uh, pretty much all the advice
that I give in there is still good.
So, it's just going to be like a bigger,
more updated version of that that covers
more stuff.
But pretty much by the time like if
you've built five environments, by like
environment number five, you're going to
be pretty good at this stuff.
training an agent to solve a very
complex robotic operation with long
horizon.
Fortunately using Isaac lab skl, but
we're considering integrating puffer
liib for your model benchmarks. Issue is
developing the end and fixing the bugs
taking some time. Yeah, Isaac will do
that. I had to do some stuff with Isaac
Jim for a client. It was a pain. I don't
know if you've seen in the last few
days, we actually have Puffer Live
working with Manny Scale. I can push
some of this stuff if you want. Um, we
will have it pushed anyways in a bit.
Uh, that mostly just works. The only
thing is that the defaults that people
use in robotics are moderately insane
for all their algorithms. So like
pretty much it's going to take us quite
a bit of optimization to make it as fast
or faster than the existing stuff in
that space. specifically because like
the combination of insane reward
functions and like weird model
architectures
and like weird hyperp combines to be
this very locally optimal thing and you
kind of have to reoptimize everything in
order to like really beat it and uh
that's just like kind of complicated
like I have to set up a big sweep
basically to do that. So, that is in the
cards and I was working on that earlier.
That's this week. I kind of just got
bored. So, I wanted to do some of the
drone stuff uh yesterday and today
they're not better than Isaac Lab. Isaac
Jim was just a student work.
How's the code? Like some of the
packages that we had to work with in
Isaac gym were just awful. And from what
I've seen, even like Isaac Sim, they
still use the same packages. Like people
like load, maybe this is humanoid
specific, but they have like motion lib
and pose lib and like all these other
just janky like an old horribly
overabstracted uh grad student code
libraries.
So Manny was at least like relatively
easier to get stuff set up and working.
Isaac Jim is better develop from
scratch. Isaac lab.
Isaac can better develop from scratch.
Isaac lab. Finally.
Very similar to Manny's skill. slightly
more complex with more trying to relying
on this. Yeah.
So, I mean,
robotics is an area that I don't really
intend to get super deep into quite soon
unless it would basically it would take
a company being really really interested
in wanting to work with us uh to bring
our type of tech to robotics, then I
would do it. But like it's not like a a
short side project level of an effort,
right? Like I pretty much have to rip
apart the really overly abstracted way
that a lot of stuff is done in robotics
and distill it down and simplify it and
then find all the things making stuff
slow and janky, right? That I'm sure are
there. It's the same thing I would I did
with the rest of RL. I'd have to bring
over to robotics.
I basically I would it would have to be
like a company would want to would have
to want like a big contract for us to go
do that because otherwise it's a huge
huge time investment that takes me off
of a lot of the stuff I'm doing outside
of
like the main thing I'm doing outside of
this stream now is basically
looking for pro like valuable problems
in industry to throw this stuff on. Um,
both because that's going to like really
help us benchmark and test puffer, but
also uh you know that solves the that
will solve the revenue
uh the revenue problem. So that'll like
let us grow way more than we are at the
moment.
Reach out to you in the next three
months. Would you be up for 12 months
guaranteed collaboration?
Yeah, I'd have to know more. Right. Um,
I don't know if you're at a company or a
lab or what because we do some level of
free support for laboratories. And then
for companies, we do uh we do paid
contracts
the company. Yeah, if you guys are
interested in something like that, we
could definitely do that. And robotics
is one of the things that I've looked
into that it like from what I've dealt
with it feels like it should be very
doable uh to bring like the puffer level
of advancements over to robotics. It's
just like a fair bit more work than I'd
want to do as a side project outside of
a contract.
Yeah.
We do two things at the moment,
Yeah. We do two things at the moment, right? We do like smaller jobs that are
right? We do like smaller jobs that are
just like support extended support and
features and then we do larger things
that are more like um
like fixed deliverables like hey we want
X built it's worth Y to us.
Shadow, can I ask if it's humanoids or
if it's more like industrial?
Is it like industrial like armbbased
stuff or is it humanoids?
Arm base. Okay, that's actually way
better. But like industrial robotics, if
I had to like do something in robotics
and pick an entry point, that's the type
of thing we'd be way more excited about
because I think that's actually going to
have way higher impact than humanoids in
the long term. Even if in the short term
we see like super hype all like tons of
companies buying humanoids yada yada I
think that folks will eventually realize
that it's like woefully impractical to
have this one-sizefits-all but like
really slow and expensive solution for
everything. Um
I personally I would love to see like
industrial robotics like the arms moving
at five times the pace that they
currently move.
I kind of see why there's the appeal to
it, but like
I don't think humanoid robots gets us
like sci-fi era awesome tech everywhere.
You know, that's kind of the way I look
at a lot of stuff. Humanoids is like
it's faster horses. You're basically
you're replacing human workers with
something that's going to be maybe about
as effective as a human worker. Like
eh
exactly what we're doing.
Be happy to chat. Long horizon multitask
optimize policies.
I've actually been thinking about stuff
like that and how you solve. So
basically, I could solve your long
horizon problem pretty much out of the
box if your Sims were fast enough.
That's the key annoyance at the moment.
Um,
so I've been thinking of like if there's
a way to do like super low fidelity,
very domain randomized, and then like
fine-tune up to faster or like to
slower, higher precision.
There are a lot of knobs that need to be
messed with. The Sims are just really
slow right now.
I think that's the main annoyance.
It really doesn't feel to me like from
first principles either that like
you know if you can run a humanoid at
10,000 steps per second statebased can
only run an arm at like 40,000 steps per
second with the same settings. It seems
like just like a six degree of freedom
arm. It seems to me like you should be
able to run it at least in like hundreds
of thousands with reasonable fidelity.
and like current Sims just aren't doing
it. I could be wrong, but just like
based on what I know about the problem,
given that they're not even doing like
they're not even doing like gel sensors
or anything like that, it stuff should
be a lot faster than it is.
Like, oh, it's built on physics and
physics is fast, therefore our thing
must be fast is not not really it.
You know,
we're just two AI engineers and a plus
years of RL experience. Once we have a
simple bug-free end, get to the level of
first real robot deployment, I'm going
to call you. Sounds good.
Yeah, man. Good luck with that. Robotics
is hot at the moment, but it's also it's
it's a tough problem in the sense that
like all the Sims and tools are really
big and bloated. This is kind of the
problem I had to solve with RL in
general, right? Like just stuff like
RLIB and SP3
um and like Gym and Gymnasium with their
vectorzation and rappers and things.
Everything was bloated and slow
and you just had to like cut off all the
fat and it just took forever. But you
got we got to a point eventually where
stuff is just good now.
For me, I've been working in RL since
well, I started neural MMO I believe in
20 2018, maybe 2017 or 2018.
Okay. Why is the observation out of
bounds here?
one.
9 13
What I messed up here?
Says 31.
RL lib kills me. I don't Yeah,
the thing is
the devs actually really tried hard with
that and like I know some of them.
It's just
I actually I got a message I think like
from a random engineer not realizing
like all the stuff I've done trying to
hire me for like RL lib. I don't
It's like it's just not how you build
for RL. You don't build a super heavy
fang style
product or a field where everything is
cursed and breaks constantly. You build
the simplest, most compact possible
thing, the smallest number of moving
parts. That's how you build it.
I've tried to help him a few different
times as well, but
What the heck did I break? What did I
break here, man? This is simple.
It's very simple. What did I break?
Hey, Tyloian. Welcome.
Luck on runs.
We have one cool experiment. So, this is
a couple cool things. This is 2048. It
looks like we've gotten some solves out
of this.
And um we also have a pretty promising
neural MMO run over here. Very promising
actually.
So this is the current one and then this
is the uh the soda
from before.
So this is the uh the run that I wrote
my article about and this is the new
run. So basically, if it gets the same
sort of curvature, which it looks like
it might start to be getting, then it
should be state-of-the-art. We'll see.
Y'all with Muan.
If anybody wants to figure out how PSGD,
like how to set up PSGD and have it
actually work, uh, I'm open to trying
other stuff as well. Like I can set up a
big run like this, but some basically
you'd have to actually set it up so it's
not going to just crash instantly. We
don't want to do this.
This isund
something very odd is happening that
this is out of bounds then, right?
I'm dumb.
Yeah, I I have an off by one.
That's all it is.
Started ML like one month ago. Welcome
to the space. There's lots of cool stuff
you can do in here.
Not good with the basics.
I have uh references for new ML people
that I always suggest.
The S231N is probably the best like
one-stop shop overall deep learning
reference. The lectures with either
Carpathy or Justin Johnson. Either of
those are good.
Do you think I should go further? It
really depends on your level of
background and especially like how good
of a programmer you are. How's your
math? What areas are interesting to you?
Like what do you want to do, right?
I have my quick start guide for RL on
the uh the website puffer.ai. It's also
on X.
Super super cool you live stream this. I
wish more people did. Yeah, it's been
fun. I uh I like live streaming all the
work.
It's been great for the project as well.
We've had like several people from the
live stream come and just say, "Hey, you
know, I want to start building some
stuff." And uh you know, many have been
very successful at it even without AI
experience.
Thinking of being a quant analyst,
I don't think they even do any like
super crazy
I don't think they even really do any
crazy stuff with ML.
I think a lot of it's like pretty basic
models that they use and it's a lot more
just about getting data that other
people don't have.
Where's the implementation of trajectory
segment filtering? Yes, it's included
So if you look at pufferl
where all the code is right
you can see here
hang on
right Here you can see that we're not
just iterating over the batch, right?
We're actually sampling and we're
sampling based on these pryo probs. This
is prioritized experience replay using
the advantage function uh as the metric.
So it throws away low advantage segments
low or high. I believe it is
Like
it throws away like things that are
uninformative. Basically low absolute
value.
You help me to understand what project
you're doing right now.
Uh, I'm kind of in the middle of a
couple different things, but pretty much
we have this drone sim. I guess I can
show this one. This one's a lot like
this one's in a good spot. So, this is a
drone. It flies through rings. This is a
sim. I'm building a sim in which you
have a whole bunch of drones and you can
kind of command them to do different
things.
And then we're going to reinforcement
learn the drones to be able to do that.
Doing it for full. No, it's over
trajectory segments.
It's segments of length of BPTT horizon.
Okay. So, I we pretty much have the full
sim except for the fact that for some
reason I still have this math wrong on
the circle somehow.
And then your sample
1 minus
x over the num agents
* 2 * the radius
Just going to guess that that's what I
messed up.
Huh?
Yeah. Why is this not
Why is this doing this?
Can't understand what you're doing.
I would suggest
we have some good resources right here.
we have uh there's this quick start
guide.
This gives you a lot of the basics of RL
and a lot of the intuition for stuff.
And also I these some of these need to
be reformatted at the top. But yeah,
we also have the uh the docs for this
whole project
and like tons of examples.
I'm building a I'm building a simulator
right now for
essentially for a swarm of drones to
behave in a certain way and then I'm
going to run reinforcement learning to
make the drones actually learn to do
that
with puffer lab.
Apply each point.
Okay.
There we go. That's a sphere.
Yeah, that's a sphere, right?
We're good.
Let's do some basic thing first with
this. See if we can get it to Turn.
Okay,
training is stable. So, I guess I didn't
horribly break everything in this latest
change.
See whether it does anything.
article really did very well. I only
have one other article with 100,000
views and it was kind of like a
loweffort batty article.
So, this is kind of nice to see a actual
technical uh article do this well.
What do you do for a living? This
I do reinforcement learning work
full-time.
Hey Anick,
thanks for the shout out. Appreciate if
you missed it. I pushed a small change
on GitHub to make it interactable.
Article's going wild. Many views on
Puff. Yeah, it's very good. Did you see
the latest sweep that I did, Yanick?
You will uh you will appreciate this for
sure.
So, this is 600 million steps and this
is 2048.
So, uh, we found some good parameters.
Apparently,
Neptune is so slow.
They advertise it's like the fastest or
whatever, but it's really not.
So, it looks like they don't all know
exactly where they're supposed to go.
It's pretty close.
Interesting. If it continues to solve
based on the curves, it looked like it
it looks like it should.
I will grab those hypers later and we
can play around with it.
Or I could link if you want to play
around with it. I can link you this
here. I put the sweep in the dev chat.
See if that link works.
Each drone have its own target point.
Now it does. Yes.
Okay, this should make it substantially
easier to learn.
Got 470 before.
Yeah, we can far. We can push the ends.
I think it's a quite good environment
actually.
There really aren't that many things
that take that many steps to learn like
on the uh like the game environments
and the episodes are not like crazy long
either.
It's a good environment.
Thank you for the contribution.
10x improvement.
Yeah, I this is what we've sort of seen
with a lot of my work, right?
Sweeps are kind of just ridiculously
overpowered. Oh, yeah. This is also with
a simpler and smaller model than uh the
one that you used. So
Uh this got 470 before, did it not?
Hang on. Let me go get the I closed the
tab because Neptune was crashing stuff.
So, I guess we'll see whether this helps
it stay stable and keep learning or not.
All I did was uh this experiment is I
relativized the observations. Actually,
you know what I should do? Every time I
think of a thing that's like a basic
trick that I want to talk about,
I'm going to just put it into the bottom
as a note.
Okay, so this looks maybe a little
better.
Uh, still kind of crashing a bit though.
Yeah, it still ended up a little tiny
bit better.
I guess what you would expect.
Here's drone sphere.
we train them for all the tasks
simultaneously.
I get to delete four
dimensions
from the obace.
So that is
20.
Wait, am I stupid?
27.
Yeah.
Or I cannot add
Seven.
Okay.
we rebuild this and we see if we can do
all four tasks simultaneously.
So, this is actually a fair bit easier
because you really don't even need to
know what task you're doing in order to
do this. You just need to know where the
target is. But, let it be known that we
actually had a version of this working
pretty well even without that. So like
task conditional RL kind of just works
which is crazy because that's not a like
that's not a thing at all that used to
Dark.
if task conditional RL works now, yeah,
there's some crazy demos we can throw
together from
I have the score normalized such that or
the perf normalized especially such that
I think one is ideal like it's working
perfectly but I don't think you can
actually get one.
So hopefully this should be like
reasonably good behavior. here.
Oh yeah, this is working. And they're
trying not to crash as well.
obviously we have to fix these drone
trails and stuff
way better. And I we'll fix this.
Actually, we'll do this next. We'll just
fix this next. And then we'll add in the
rest of the tasks and then we will be
pretty well set. Like we'll have an
awesome drone sim that works with RL in
like day and a half of like pretty lazy
work.
All right. I'd be right back.
we'll do the two component reward. In
fact,
all sore today and I don't know why
a bunch of pull-ups and like some pearls
yesterday anything else
Oh, I guess then this does get
does get updated, huh?
Yeah, you can do
when I'm assessing a new area of work, I
always look for wrong fundamental
assumptions. Why puffer will win?
Pretty much what we do.
I mean,
I kind of have a probably not as great
of an outlook on it in how I get to that
conclusion, which is like I kind of
every I kind of assume everything is
done in the stupidest and most
incompetent way possible until proven
otherwise.
And like when I see a few things done
incompetently, I look for other things
done incompetently.
Okay, we do actually need this stuff as
well, but
it can go into compute
board.
Okay. Episode length
or
get absor.
Yeah.
Now, the only thing I have to do besides
this, making sure that I I didn't pass
anything else up.
Decision reward, target reward, and
that's it.
May as well let it see, right? Let there
be light.
And we also wanted to fix the trails,
right?
really. I would think that this would do
it. Now.
Oh, hang on. I think it just indexed
wrong somehow.
thought this would be it.
Really good references in your quick
start blog. Thank you. I am working on
another one. I've started on like
another educational article. It's going
to be much longer.
Uh, and it's going to take me quite a
bit of work.
I'm just kind of doing it bit by bit,
but
I'm working on that.
Costa is
I think Costa is like the only person
the only other person in Arl where I'd
like I have literally nothing negative
to say about Costa at all. Costa is just
awesome.
Like it's one of these things where I
don't think the field realizes how
screwed reinforcement learning would be
without Costa.
Like including all the stuff I do. Like
we would just be beyond screwed.
Why does this guy have both trails and
this other one doesn't have any?
Oh, this needs to be zero.
Now they both get trails.
When it's out of bounds, you reset the
agent and terminals is set to one.
very weird that this thing does this.
How does the trail jump on reset like
this?
It's like the frame after they reset or
whatever, right?
Okay. So, this is just not doing
anything I guess.
Oh,
you are stupid is why.
Okay, they still zap though like this.
Why this is out?
Is it just drawing it somewhere else and
I'm just dumb?
No,
this is where it's drawing it.
Okay. Okay. So, you can actually see
that it is wrapping around and screwing
it
This terminated condition does work.
The heck is wrong?
Hello,
your potato.
Uh, this is a live reinforcement
learning dev. I'm currently working on a
drone simulator.
Show you a different version.
Okay, apparently I don't have it. I can
show you this version at least.
So, we have a couple different drone
simulators and I'm currently working on
a version that has a ton of different
drones that can like fly in a sphere or
hover or like do a few different things
and we're training them with
reinforcement learning.
That is currently what is going on.
You can watch some of these live in your
browser at puffer.ai.
You have all sorts of games and
simulators and other things.
This is a trained agent playing it in
your browser.
This is a trained agent that plays in
We have lots of different things in
here.
I'm currently just trying to figure out
why these uh trails on these drones are
not rendering correctly.
Stuck on a very basic thing at the
moment.
Yeah. See, it like it zaps and like
follows them for some reason.
It's like an off by one or some weird
thing.
I honestly don't know why this is doing
this.
We can just re
do how the trail works a little. So you
get the position.
that. Well, that wasn't it, but
hang on. It's something like this.
I forgot how the indexing was done
originally.
Probably just in
I see. Yeah, this wasn't designed to be
used this way. Okay. So, we have to
redesign a little bit.
I see no the original is actually
correct.
Do like this
up to this cap.
And it should be that you count
backwards.
Just not by one now I believe. Think how
we do this
back. Okay.
I hate when I get stuck on silly things
like this.
It's just like it needs to be done, but
I'm stuck for some dumb reason.
like incredibly incredibly basic as
well.
Literally just a ring buffer.
This is really the simplest way to do it
as well, isn't it?
Hey man, I'm not from a coding
background. Should I learn coding?
I mean, if you want to, right? I don't
know. It's your life, man.
I'm sure I just have the like the modulo
arithmetic screwed up in some dumb way.
If you want to see some cool demos,
there's some stuff on puffer.ai.
some of the agents that we've got.
Thank you for the reminder for folks.
Linky, do star the puffer all open
source code. It's on GitHub. Find the
link at puffer.ai.
The repo helps us out a lot.
give up. Going to just debug it like
this.
I don't have anything on that does that.
It just does it automatically.
Yeah, these numbers are way too big,
aren't they?
That was annoying, but whatever. We got
it.
Okay,
we are ready.
See how this looks.
Lab the new rewards in. You'd be able to
have this cleaned up for today.
The article got more than twice as many
views as the release that literally
rewrites reinforcement learning.
Crazy.
love the new video today.
Oh, the trailer that I put online.
Yeah, I realized that I had not I hadn't
put our release trailer from X onto uh
onto YouTube. So, I uploaded as as a uh
I uploaded the 1080p one and then I also
uploaded the shorts one.
Don't underestimate the power of
Schwarz. Yeah, I've uploaded a few small
things and they do well. It's funny. Oh,
hey Arin. Yes, now I remember. Compan
things. I saw it naturally in YouTube
reals.
That's the algorithm.
Okay. So, can we do eval?
Have it look decent now.
me to create a channel. My friend, I'm
preparing a review paper on machine
learning force fields. Very cool.
As you can see on the uh the channel, I
don't really post a ton of like videos.
They're a ton of work. I have uh I have
like 400 something live streams though
on the channel so far. And um
I also I mean I write articles. I post
those on X
fighting start discussing a lot of RL
and chemistry. Absolutely.
You account for the turbulence caused by
other drones in the area.
No, that should be accounted for by just
telling them not to slam into each other
or get too
What RL methods are the drones using
currently? It's the main trainer in Papa
Lip, which is not exactly PO. It's quite
a bit better, but it's based on it.
Okay.
Add the uh the task for them to form a
line, I guess.
target.
I see.
But I do need to figure this last thing
out, which is I need to figure out a
separate way to set the target and then
uh move the target, I guess.
target. Idle
target
Okay, so this works.
This is just going to be set target
orbit.
dinner soon.
Going to end first.
Got the target and the line
update function.
The only ones that need update
we have idle
Follow.
What are you fixing now? I'm making I'm
just adding a bunch of tasks. The goal
is you're going to have like a whole
bunch of different tasks that the drones
can do and now uh or like commands they
can follow and uh I'm adding that
What was your school experience like?
What were the biggest rewards and
takeaways?
I'm usually I'm pretty negative for the
most part. uh overall on like
traditional coursework to learn stuff.
I guess it's more like the vast majority
of the courses are not well taught. Some
are. The ones that are good are very
good, but the majority are just kind of
a waste of time.
Um
for PhD, it's not really school in the
same way. At least not in CS. like you
take to a total of four courses that
aren't really relevant or helpful in any
way to what you're doing. There really
isn't course work that you can do that's
going to be relevant to the research.
It's kind of just up to you to like
teach yourself and figure it out.
Couple of the intro courses in undergrad
were good. I had one really good ML
course. I had like a couple decent
miscellaneous other ones and other than
that, I mean, I spent like half of my
time in undergrad just doing research.
Like I was pretty much doing full-time
AI research starting sophomore year, a
little earlier.
Think if there's anything else like
super interesting
takeaways.
A lot of the stuff has just been you
need to spend a ludicrous amount of time
learning the thing and like use the
materials that are good to learn, but
very often it's just going to be you
have to figure stuff out and it's going
to be slow and it's going to be a grind
because there just isn't material out
there that you can use to like be taught
it. Basically, you have to learn it
yourself.
I mean, it literally took me like I
think it took me well over a thousand
hours to figure out the basics of neural
nets because there were just zero good
resources back then at all.
That was even a little before undergrad
to be fair.
But yeah, like when I took the uh the
main Stanford ML course, it was
completely irrelevant and it didn't even
touch on neural nets at all. Um
I think if anything else
I don't know if you have other
specifics, I can answer stuff.
learning takes time. Well, it's like
a lot of the coursework isn't even going
to help you. Like take RL specifically.
You can perfectly, you can go take an RL
course and understand everything
perfectly and get a 100red in the course
and have absolutely no idea what you're
doing.
Like I literally have people that spend
a few days going through some of the
stuff that I've done and they have a
better understanding than if you go read
the entire Sutton and Bardau book.
I don't know. Like academia has a way of
teaching stuff and a language by which
they teach stuff. They kind of just like
to beat you over the head with math
until you like get bored and stop, I
guess.
But like they'll do it even if it has no
practical application or it's like not
even fully correct. They'll just do it
anyways.
I don't know. This has been one of the
things I've been pretty good at, right?
Is like identifying gaps in the way that
things are done and then just doing it a
completely different way.
I got into my CS masters and I have gaps
in math only fill them after I finish
grad. My trying to do it along courses
research is much honestly most of the
math in RL is like wrong.
Most of the RL math is just wrong.
There are very small bits of math that
actually matter.
like the whole basis of a lot of stuff
it's like all derived from tabular
Q-learning on MDPs
and it's just a mess. Yes.
Please mention what needs to be changed.
I'm working on an article that will
cover a lot of it. Um, it's mainly like
they do 10 times too much math and 10
times too little engineering.
Like they don't care about solving the
problem. They care about doing a bunch
of math. It's weird. like they care
about writing fancy algorithms and like
running their experiments and like
saying a better than b even though
statistically it makes no sense. It's
like there's like a very cookie cutter
way that stuff is done
and that worked up to a point and then
when it was time to actually like make
all this stuff fast enough so that that
approach could continue to be useful,
everybody kind of just threw up their
hands, didn't do it, and let the field
die.
I'm not even remotely exaggerating.
RL is a field where understanding a
little bit about the history of like how
stuff has developed over the last few
years will do you a lot more good than
like understanding 20 algorithm.
This is a generic question. I'm a
third-year undergrad and ideally you
want to be some kind of ML research or
applied scientist. Pretty comfortable
with understanding the latest
developments in LMS and based models.
Okay, that's a lot of math. So, you're
probably set there. Minus RL. If you
were me, what would you focus on right
now? I don't know what I should do to
achieve my goals.
Research engineer or applied scientist?
Yeah. So, research engineer is a little
bit trickier because it's usually like
they kind of just grab people out of
masters or whatever. um for re like for
ML research and then also qualifies you
for research engineer positions doing a
bit of your own research is probably
good publishing something is probably
good. Um, so getting to the point that
you can function autonomously like that
is good. And then on the engineering
side, just like if you want to go that
route, then just do the exact same
thing, but do it with an engineering
heavy approach, right?
like focus on doing stuff that is
engineering intensive and also produces
a cool result that you can publish
instead of like
the traditional one which is the
traditional science thing where like
scientists can't write code at all.
I don't know. That's the vague general
advice I have today.
appreciate it a lot. Yeah, you can look
at like my RL specific thing. There's a
quick start guide on puffer.ai. It has a
lot of good reference material.
I mean, my path was pretty much that I
started research really early on. I
didn't really have a specific topic of
interest. So I started doing some
natural language processing because that
was the lab that was there and then I
went and I did some computer vision. I
managed to publish one thing in natural
language processing. Put a couple just
archive manuscripts out on vision stuff
and then I came up with the idea for
neural MMO and I learned the RL and all
the stuff around it to make that happen.
I did that for my whole PhD and then in
the last year year and a half I started
doing puffer and the goal here is to use
all the knowledge I gained about RL to
make RL a faster ser more stable field
because I saw that as a gap
a lot of science is a lot more cookie
cutter than the path that I've taken
uh the path that I've taken is like the
very high variance path
where you're kind of just going to get
stomped a lot of the time because
researchers don't like it when you do
work this way. Uh but you're also going
to be able to solve problems that nobody
else can.
So that's the that's what I can speak
to.
all very impressive. Oh, thank you. It's
most of what I do, so I would hope it
is.
Hey, what's going on? Can I get a quick
overview? Uh, this is reinforcement
learning dev. I stream all of my
research. I'm currently working on a
drone environment where you can send
commands to make drones go in uh arrange
themselves in a variety of patterns and
follow each other and do stuff like
that.
If you want to check out some cool
demos, they're all on puffer.ai. You
have agents that play games and like do
other fun stuff all in your browser.
advice on YouTube versus Twitch
streaming? Free automation tool? I
stream on both. I just do it through
reream.
And I don't know what you mean for free
automation tools
how to make the posts get automated.
Message everything externally.
Do you mean how to make the post get
automated?
post
it just like YouTube just shows up.
YouTube will just record your VODs
automatically for you. You don't have to
do anything.
Twitch will record them, but it won't
store them forever. That's just Twitch
being Twitch. Nothing you do about that.
YouTube is really going to be your main
archive. Uh X will store I don't know
how many. I think X has a cap, but it'll
store the last many. Um,
X automatically posts your stream when
you stream YouTube. It automatically
shows up in the live tab and it gets
recommended to people. Same for Twitch.
You really don't need any like extra
tools. You do need something like Reream
to make it a little easier to stream
simultaneously to many services.
Oh yeah, this is going to be really
good.
Thanks a lot. How would you learn RL
teach RL to beginner researchers? The uh
I'm making another one of these, but the
quick start guide on my website is very
good.
Like that's literally it. Do that. Start
building environments.
If you already know how to program, you
can literally start doing RL over a
weekend. If you don't know how to
program, well, then that's the hard
part, right?
here. So you can see that there are all
sorts of different configurations.
Some are stationary, some are mobile.
Uh, and I'm going to I'm defining a
bunch of these and I'm going to
reinforcement learn these drones such
that they can uh do any of those
patterns. They can arrange themselves in
any of those patterns.
Uh, almost
white.
make it better later. I want to at least
get it to run.
What's your recommended way of
understanding a given environment?
Know in it step and a reset function.
Well, understanding like one of the
puffer environments, you can mostly read
it from top to bottom.
Um,
like these are like except for some of
the messier ones, they're mostly written
in as simple as possible basic C. But
like go watch it. If it's playable, play
it a little bit.
If it's playable, play it a little bit.
That helps a lot.
try this. Um,
yeah, mostly it's like playing the
environment. The way you design rewards
is less even to do. There are a couple
RL specific things you need to know, but
like the biggest thing honestly is just
knowing what information the agent needs
to solve the task and like what signal
makes sense
to actually tell you how to solve the
task. It's like not even RL specific,
right? It's just like basic first
principles reasoning
wrong here. It's Sixide by 8
and 8
0 to 7.
from the ML side where is the
observation space, action space and
reward stuff. So the actual shape of it
is in the Python file
um
and that gets passed in as just a
pointer. So you just have a pointer to
the observations
and then usually most ends have like a
compute observation
function or it'll be inlined
inside of the step function and then
reward similarly either there's either
going to be a function or it'll be
inlined in the step function.
Okay, this is I think this is correct.
Good.
Okay, so this is now trained on I
believe seven or eight tasks.
See,
seven tasks.
One of them is just do like it's like an
idle task.
One of them is to hover in place. One of
them is to be in this like spherical
orbit thing.
There's a follow task where you have to
follow a single target. There's a line
task where they all have to put
themselves into a line. Congo task where
they got to follow each other. There's a
plane task.
Should be able to do some stuff with
this.
And that's a decent policy in like
literally 30 seconds as well. He'll get
better, but this is a very good start, I
would say.
This looks very fun. How do I get
involved? It's all open source
puffer.ai.
Wait till you see this result as soon as
this thing is trained.
These are all the ends. Uh most of these
are made by contributors. Some of them
are made by me.
There is uh documentation on how to get
started. We suggest that most new
contributors start by going through the
quick start guide on the blog here.
And then you're going to want to write
an environment.
Typically, like you look for something
that's fun that you can do in maybe a
few hundred lines of code, not a massive
project. People have come up with all
sorts of stuff. We like things that are
interesting, like interesting challenges
for RL in a new way. We also like things
that are just cool and interesting. Like
here, Tetris ended up being really cool
to watch. Just Tetris, but like look how
cool it is to watch the AI play it.
Like mesmerizing, right?
We had somebody submit 2048 and uh you
know, completely counterintuitively,
this ended up being actually a very
useful environment for research.
As it turns out, it's actually kind of
hard.
Is this sick? Happy I stumbled across
you. Thank you. Here, let me show you
this thing real quick
because we just trained this model.
Okay, so if I hold tab, this will show
you the target objectives. They do a
pretty decent job of uh going to these
targets.
And if we sort of change up the tasks,
so this is just a do whatever task,
don't collide.
We've got a hover task which is stay in
place.
Orbit follow the single dot. Got this
line task.
Arrange themselves in a line. Got this
congo task.
I need to make it so it doesn't reset so
frequently so you can actually see. They
are doing a congo though. You can kind
of see it.
It could be a little better, but not bad
for a first result plane.
That was quick. Yeah. So, this is the
thing with Puffer, right? It's literally
a thousand times faster than everything
that else that is out there in
reinforcement learning. You can
literally train superhuman models in
seconds.
Like this pong agent here, you know how
long it takes to train this pong agent?
Okay, so this is something that would
take like hours or days uh before puffer
lib. This is how long it takes to train
Pong.
There you go. There's your agent that
plays pong. You're the blue one,
obviously.
So yeah, this is what I do all day. This
is all open source. We do our own RL
research on the algorithms. We do our
own crazy infrastructure to make
everything fast. We write tons of
environments for use in research and
applications.
Uh yeah, this is this is the main thing.
What did you optimize so well? We tore
out and rewrote the whole stack. The
result is actually pretty concise. like
our code is actually a lot simpler than
the other things out there as well even
though it's this fast but the
environments are in C very simple C but
it's C uh they write observations
directly into shared memory so like you
can have thousands of environments and
all the data is immediately available on
the main process without redundant
copies
trainers optimized for super large
batches which is not usual we optimize
the heck out of a lot of the overhead on
the trainer as well
we
And we made some fundamental algorithm
improvements that let you do that more
effectively.
The mix of a lot of things.
This is what I think this is the first
environment that I did in pure state is
this snake environment. It's maybe 300
linesish of code. very very simple
environment but cool each snake is an
agent.
What batch sizes are we talking about?
So I think our most common training
setting at this point is 8192
environments or agents. So if you have a
multi- aent environment you count total
number of agents. 8192 agents and a
batch size of about 500,000. and our
biggest experiments. If you haven't seen
this article, this is this is a pretty
cool article.
So this one here, we did RL on a pabyte
of data. So uh it was 640 billion steps
or 640 billion observations. And this
one used a batch size of 3 million.
You deploy a neural net for each trained
agent. What's the data format of the
policy when you save it? It is the same
neural network executed independently.
So they're not the same agent. They are
completely independent of each other. Uh
but they share the same logic.
And my PhD is in multi-agent RL. There
are a lot of other things you can do.
Some of them make sense, but mostly it's
kind of best to just do it this way.
This
not log in this.
Oh, yes.
Probably needs to be swept. Batch size 3
million. I'm going to go read up.
Yeah, we have some pretty cool stuff. I
think the best agent Very nice work,
Kingpuffer. Thank you. The best agent
that we have is the uh so the one
pedabyte agent is available on the
website.
It plays neural MMO 3. Takes a second to
load in because now it's loading a
neural net and stuff. Um
so this is a big game. Oops.
I think I hit escape by mistake. Escape
is mapped to uh
undo. Hang on.
Did we break it?
When does tab break it?
Oh, that's obnoxious.
You should be able to zoom out on the
map.
I didn't even push an update to this
thing recently.
Well, apparently I can't zoom out to
show you how big the map is, but the
trailer for that is on X. Actually, you
know what? No, I totally can because I
have it locally.
Neural MMO policy is only 3 million
parameters. All right, this is the map.
It's not actually fractal, but we It's I
left it this way because we do actually
train on multiple maps at the same time,
so it makes sense.
So, it's like this big MMO.
And
if you watch the agent, you'll see that
it's capable of using tools. It gets
equipment. It knows how to put stuff on.
It knows how to fight. It knows how to
kite enemies. Sometimes it even knows
how to sell and buy items on this
marketplace.
like a 3.4 million parameter-ish
network.
This is our best agent. I would say
I wrote an article about this. I
subjectively consider this result to be
better than emergent tool use and
capture the flag, but uh nowhere near as
good as something like Alpha Star and
Dota
based on my own subjective opinion. So
deal with it.
Option space there is huge.
in neural MMO. Yeah, you'd think so. But
guess what? I have the action space
mapped to something like a discrete of
26.
That's part of energy design.
It's a bit ry. I mean, I'd hope it's
cool. I've literally neural MMO was the
topic of my entire PhD and two years
worth of research before that.
Yeah, thank you. We're not done with it
either. I literally have um I have an
experiment going right now.
It's doing another one pabyte experiment
at the moment.
This is approximately
uh 350 terabytes. No wait is it 350?
Yeah, 350 terabytes into training and
currently it is doing
pretty dang well.
Can you say what hardware you're running
this on?
You see right behind me,
you see the white boxes up on the
shelves? Those are tiny boxes. There's
six GPUs a piece, six 4090s.
And uh we ran these experiments. Just
need one of those boxes to run an
experiment like this for maybe three
days, three to four days.
You don't need a crazy amount of
hardware. You need a little bit of
hardware, not a crazy amount.
This is the only thing in Puffer that
requires a multiGPU machine as well.
Nothing else requires multiGPU.
Everything else you can train at home on
like a single 4090
3080 or whatever if you have one. It'll
just take long, right?
You're never going to be out of memory
for the most part.
Okay, let me get this stuff configured.
I got to go to dinner soonish. I want to
make sure that we get a sweep going on
this
read up on the details. This is awesome.
Thanks. Hey, I hope you enjoy. We're
always looking for new contributors. So,
if you want to get involved with
research, be very happy for the help.
stream every day. I do not stream seven
days a week. I do occasionally rest. Uh
I mostly stream at the moment on
reasonable hours Eastern time subject to
other meetings and stuff that I have to
take. So, most of the day EST,
sometimes in the evenings, depends how,
you know, depends how I'm feeling.
Sometimes I work late as well. Uh,
usually stream like Monday through
Saturday.
Now, the thing is I am going in uh in
like a week. I'm going to Palo Alto. So,
I'll be on Pacific for a bit and I'll
probably be having a lot of like
business meetings to deal with because
that's the point of being there right by
SF. All sorts of meetings. Then I'm
going to RLC. So, I will be at RLC in
person for uh presenting Puffer Lib
Puffer Lib 2, which is old at this
point, but that's the paper that got
accepted. And then I'll be back in Po
Alto for a few weeks and then I'll be
back here for quite a while.
Oh, it's not super consistent when, but
the number of hours is quite cons. That
makes sense.
Well,
we could still use uh some larger
contracts, right?
We have a
slightly profitable private RL lab.
Ideally, we could have a very profitable
private RL lab and then we can fund way
more research.
Make that happen for sure. I hope so as
well. I think we should be good.
I pretty much just need to be spending
uh a decent chunk of time looking for
good applications where we can really uh
solve people's problems with RL.
Sort of been doing that passively over
the last weeks since the release.
Find a couple of those and we should
get back to doing more research.
Have you looked at chip optimization
with RL? Planning to give that a go
soon.
It's a much harder problem because it's
a placement problem. You kind of just
have to zero shot output the entire
chip.
We do have some good RL stuff, so it's
possible we could do something there.
I've sort of thought about it. It's not
anywhere near as easy of an application
for initial entry point into industry.
Um, we actually almost got a client in
that space quite a while ago just on
like the general RL tech that we were
doing.
need a high-speed simulator is a big
barrier. Yep. Are there workarounds that
you could invent? Yes, there very much
are. And that is the uh the subject of
quite a bit of research. I think we are
better positioned than anybody else to
do that research. But the thing is like
we kind of already have a bunch of
valuable tech. So my plan for the time
being is to find useful areas where we
can build fast simulators. Uh make the
company much more profitable doing a
couple of those things and then invest
that to do the research to make RL work
in other areas. Right? That seems the
most sensible course to me.
Can we just appreciate that this thing
is running at 4 million steps per
second? By the way,
thing is running like an overnight the
equivalent of like an overnight
experiment from my PhD every two
seconds.
All right, we'll leave this here and
then this will uh run us a nice hyper
pram sweep.
What else do I want to do on this? I may
as well just clean it up for a little
bit right now before I have to head for
dinner. I'm going to head out just a
little bit early, I think, as well. My
uh my family is visiting. They just got
here. Um, but let me real quick I just
want to rename it real
I'm back. How much of the drone code
have you written by yourself? How much
of it is off this shelf? Such a huge
space. We have two undergrads who are
helping with the drone stuff. Uh they
wrote I will show you their sim.
None of it's off the shelf though,
that's for sure.
So Finn and Sam, who are in the Discord,
wrote this.
I helped a little bit with some of the
learning, but they wrote this.
trained with Puffer Lib.
And then in the last like day and a
half, I modified this. I made a version
of it that has supports a bunch of
drones. And then I instead of having
ring targets, I have a configuration
that's essentially just like tells the
drone to follow an instruction. There's
Finn. Finn's one of the authors of this.
You'll see, Larry, that um like a lot of
the stuff in Puffer Lib, it's like these
crazy things, but it ends up just being
a few hundred lines of code with the way
we build everything.
Like the more complicated stuff ends up
being a few thousand lines of code. But
I think all of neural MMO 3, this whole
project here is under 3,000 lines.
No, it's the exact opposite. None of it
is abstracted. That's why it's short.
This is why you like you see me writing
like uh almost no dependencies C.
Environments and C. I have some practice
to do. I'm a physics grad. Oh, yeah.
Perfect. You'll be well positioned then.
That's actually super useful cuz that's
like one of the things I'm very bad at
and I love having people around who are
good at that.
We keep the C really simple though, like
really really simple.
We actually have brand new programmers
who uh who have gotten into Puffer Lab
and have been just fine.
Like this is the entire source code
right here is this 800 line file. And
I'm actually embarrassed that this is
800 lines. Like it should not be 800
lines. So I'll have to go figure out
what the heck redundant stuff I have in
here.
Okay, there we go. Still works. Commit
this.
trying to solve a fiber optic path
finding algorithm at the moment.
Cool.
The name of the game with RL is like
fast
as fast simulation as you possibly can
for interactive processes, right?
So if you have a problem that can be
formulated as an interactive process,
you can write a fast sim for it. RL is
usually a good fit. There are a few
exceptions. Stuff that relies a ton on
like language is not great. Vision is
better, but still not amazing, mainly
just because it makes the Sim slow. Um,
but other than that, yeah, you can solve
like a lot of really unintuitive
problems really, really fast with this
stuff.
Do you think pathf finding could be an
RL problem? Uh, you could turn it into
one.
Yeah, you could definitely turn it into
one. I mean, we have um
well, it actually takes a second to
train an agent to do our mazes.
Let me see if I can find the graphic of
our mazes.
It was in the one of the articles.
We have the best maze solving RL agent
that doesn't like hack it with other
stuff.
You kind of need to be familiar with RL
stuff to know how impressive this is.
Um, this maze right here, like that tiny
one. Yeah, this that's about as big as
the mazes usually get in RL. And even
that doesn't really work. And people
like hack the algorithm to force it to
work. So, this is what we got just out
of the box without really doing anything
special, just running our algorithm.
cominatorial optimizations on graphs in
the dev channel. You can definitely try
it.
It's like kind of a decent approach for
stuff where verifying the problem is
really fast,
but like can't even really get good data
on the problem because generating the
data is super slow.
See, I'll check this and then I got to
run.
we have this weird case where some
networks subsidized like free to build
so some of the edges in the nodes are
free mitations limit that's fun
I I don't know who this is just chilling
in the VC if that's what you meant
I do have to run and uh I got to run for
in there.
Okay. So, for the folks watching here,
thank you for tuning in today.
Probably won't be back after dinner.
We'll see. My family is here. Uh they're
visiting.
I will be back in the morning. So if
you're interested in all this stuff,
puffer.ai for all the things,
lots of cool projects built by
contributors here. If you want to help
me out for free, literally free in 5
seconds, just star the repo. Feed the
puffer. It really helps. Like actually
starring the repo really helps. And uh
other than that, yeah, join the Discord.
You can follow me on X for more and all
that. And I will be back tomorrow. More
reinforcement learning.